bah déjà je voudrais quand même
commenter ce premier tour que ce soit en
France à Dijon puis en Côte d'Or un taux
d'abstention encore très important comme
en
2008 et puis
aussi une une baisse de la gauche dans
le pays donc ça montre bien qu'il y a de
la déception de la part des gens qui
sont déçus aussi par par la politique
gouvernementale ce que je vois aussi sur
aussi un un climat politique et en même
temps une volonté pour certain de
comment de d'abaisser le débat et de de
de rompre avec le clivage droite gauche
on le sent aussi sur la ville de Dijon
avec certaines candidature donc
évidemment que c'est un message en tout
cas de la part du Front de gauche et de
moi-même
pour pour dire qu'il faut on va
continuer ce combat contre l'austérité
et d'ailleurs c'est pour cela que nous
appelons à à participer une grande
marche le 12 avril à Paris contre
l'austérité en France et en Europe voilà
pour le une impression de soir de
premier tour sur Dijon et pour revenir à
à Dijon est-ce que vous appelez
clairement à voter pour l'un ou l'autre
des
candidats ben dans la situation de Dijon
nous ne voulons pas n voulons pas faire
de place ni à la droite ni au Front
national nous l'avions déjà exprimé donc
nous ne voulons pas dans cette situation
là aggraver la situation et au contraire
on veut relever le défi à gauche à Dijon
et d'ailleurs nous allons continuer à à
à batailler à combattre pour pour
d'autres pour des projets qu'on a porté
pendant la campagne pendant ce premier
tour sur Dijon et dans le pays